okay for people joining this live stream
we are reviewing some
work that's been done aimed at
version 13 of awesome language
this is about symbolic representation
and creation of web
pages so ricardo take it away let's show
us an example
okay hi everyone
there is just a little led function that
helped us deploy things on the on the
cloud
why isn't that utility function
something that we build in i mean isn't
that something everybody would have to
do
well it's also doing system or when i
guess you don't want to do it every time
you evaluate
right
but the cloud export part okay go ahead
okay so you just created that page
indeed
as a cloud object
at the url
in the cloud so everything is being
created locally on my machine and then
it's deployed to the glove there's a
static webpage
okay so so let me just understand so
this code here
how would i capture the html
so let's say let's say i just want to
see in the notebook a string for the
html that came out of that stuff
sure
so we can simply do roughly the same
code
but with export string
oops
and then
um
i don't think any permissions but
you don't need the permissions
oh yeah right sorry
i need to do this
so this is the full page but if you are
interested only once she's exported then
we can remove this
and um
get exported so
so this is a bunch of styles
that are generated and compiled from the
specification that you have
and then it starts
media query in case um there is
something that needs to be done when you
resize page
which is something that is happening
here
okay all right this is wonderful okay so
i think i understand the workflow so
let's go back and look at the
specification so basically the concept
is
you are specifying a page
and then you say essentially cloud
published that page that's what we
should be able to do is take this thing
and say cloud publish it
but maybe we need another wrapper around
this called web page or something
that
tells the cloud publishing apparatus
you know how to deal with that
indeed i mean um
in a lot of design review that we have
done with this project there was always
this idea webpage
specifically here i have removed it from
the implementation because it was
unclear
how that should have been done probably
you want a web page there where the
first argument is the layout and then
you have a bunch of net information
about
[Music]
just like you have down there under your
template thing
i would think
that's a difference
i would just say web page of whatever
you have that your expression and their
metadata and then if i say cloud publish
of that web page boom
i want it there
right
right now the only thing that i would
wonder about
is what
what if that web page what if there's a
sub web page what if it's actually a
bundle of web pages you're trying to
create
you understand what i'm saying i mean
just does your thing here is your thing
here aimed at select yes
something that can be done i think there
is
something called external bundle
or url that's correct
and so
basically you will set this on the right
hand side of external bundle and uh
and yeah i mean i don't know one thing
that you want to do for sure is to
basically compile a bunch of pages into
a folder and then i don't know publish
this thing under github pages or
whatever is here then you've got
um or you can publish all the word from
cloud obviously but basically once you
add it you know into a folder with html
and everything um you're interested hold
on hold on hold on hold on you're
jumping too quickly here okay so one
thing is we have a symbolic web page
specification okay
one use of that symbolic web page
specification is cloud publish
okay
another use is just give me the html
string
another use is
put
that thing maybe it's export
maybe
i mean
we don't have a usual okay you can just
say export of food.html comma and then
this web page thing
and that would then export it to a local
file which you could then put on github
or whatever else
and then potentially
there is this idea which this would
enforce
you know reinforce
of service deploy
which is something like the github thing
you described
do you understand what i'm saying so
service deploy
is deploy this thing to an external
service is that making sense
ricardo are you are you with me sure
sure sure sure i mean i'm totally good
right i mean that's what mail receiver
function should have been implemented as
a service deploy not as a cloud deploy
right
yeah that's basically like copying a
folder to any other service like
whatever you know whatever is ftp or s3
or
another folder well i mean no those are
external that's external storage that's
a different thing again
right i mean the whole point is there is
plumbing to be done
to
you know
you you get what i'm saying
it's planning to be done
we got a bunch of people and what i say
there is nothing specific about uh
probably this project because once you
have exported this guy into a folder
with all the bundles and dependencies
you need then basically it's just a
matter of coding a folder to whatever
service you want i know but that whole
point is to not have that intermediate
folder do you understand what i'm saying
to be able to hook it up so that for
example for github sure you just say
service deploy and then it has
authentication and so on you you enter
you know because we can now you know we
we can access the system keychain we can
do all these things for authentication
right yes absolutely we can do all this
syntax sugar
right what i'm saying is it's very
important it's very very important
because that's how people will really
use this i mean if people you know like
like can i make it so that this will
just post it to my wordpress
blog thing
or can i even put it on my you know web
server right because not
self evident
that you know you can put this in the
htdocs folder or whatever it is these
days in a web in a web server
do you get what i'm saying
yes
okay let's let's take a look at what you
actually have here so i mean the main
goal of your code is to generate html
plus css is that correct
yes there is also i will show you
something else here so for example
this is a neat example
where basically you can define whatever
xml element you have
so you can you can manually specify any
kind of html and that is represented in
our language by xml element
um so i'm manually writing gears on
something that is pointing to a youtube
video
and then basically you can open it
and that is basically how uh an i frame
with a youtube video in it
well that's cool okay listen you're
jumping you're jumping ricardo can we
start at the beginning please
that
we just get rick rolled
indeed
yes he did oh my god
[Laughter]
the idea here is that you have a
function right and this is a function
with a template
um
and then you can pass some data in it
rick ricardo i think your
your life is a stand-up
whatever
presenting things
may not be yeah anyway never mind stick
to your day job
all right
okay let's go back let's go back up to
the top and let's start off and just see
how this works okay
um also do we have in in um
is
is john mcloone or anybody representing
him yes john is here okay yeah i'm here
okay
all right
and have you seen this design before
uh yes i have although it was a long
time ago um
okay but it kind of improved on initial
graph design that i put together where
unknowingly i kind of reinvented a bunch
of css
okay fine all right okay
ricardo take it from the top
top top top
okay so just explain how what what are
these elements here
okay so the idea is that you have a
function right that
um that
basically you apply to data and it
creates a layout
and so in this case i'm just creating a
function and there is extracting the
other menu and whatever else is putting
in here
so we start with our web vertical layout
so let's see um where are we why is it
doing that why isn't it just saying
i don't understand why it's creating a
function i mean why could i could choose
to create a function but it isn't the
actual raw code is not creating a
function
the raw code i could just type it in
right this is a this is a more advanced
thing that you're doing here i could
just type in my personal layout
okay find it
indeed this is just really use the road
and just
so this first web vertical layout is
this one
and it's the whole page because the size
specification says that you are creating
a vertical layout
that is taking the full space
on both
width and height
okay then you want everything that is in
it to be centered
on top
background is grey
okay all right so this is wait that that
stuff at the end is part of your web
vertical layout
indeed and this is the first this is
this one
yeah okay and then within the vertical
layout it has another vertical layout
which has this one
yeah okay fine
fine okay
where did the css that got generated
live
was that up at the header for the
html or is it embedded
everything is in line in this
implementation
so basically
this is the body then start the style
and everything is generated and then
this is all is that considered a decent
html style to put everything in line
like that
it is it is very common for uh wolfram
language stuff to be all inline because
uh you want your files to be very
self-contained
that way you only have one html file to
worry about
okay
what i'm thinking about is what if i
wanted to generate snippet
for this
yes
piece of html that i've built
indeed yes users want to make sure that
basically the styles needed were present
so basically if you run export of html
fragment so you see that here i was
doing cloud export with just shortcut
for export but full government goes
through which creates the whole page
and puts
only this guy
in the middle of the body but you can
generate only the fragment and the
fragment generates second styles
and i don't understand go back up to the
top i don't understand why you've got
that full document thing i thought we
had html fragment in html to represent
those two different cases
am i confused in
indeed but the
for
legacy reason the html
is a legacy exporter that is doing
another thing so uh let's call it html
page instead of html let's have html
fragment html page
does that make sense um
sure
okay
and that way we don't need the full
document
option right
there's no other setting for full
document other than true or false is
that true
indeed
okay so i think so html fragment would
generate the fragment and html page
would generate the whole thing but what
would it mean if i i can imagine a page
level i might want to say oh but i want
to include my own css file in the page
but in a fragment that doesn't make
sense does it does it
maybe it does i think you can i don't
see why you
shouldn't um yes i mean this is this is
part of the reason why we should
probably design next a web page for
output that allows you to do this kind
of stuff where basically it's a symbolic
representation of the
html page that contains all those you
know javascript dependencies and css
dependencies and so on and so on
okay
let's let's okay so what you've got here
is certain options i mean that that web
horizontal layout has
you've got a size and a color full 100
white
and then you've got options after that
is that correct
yes so this is roughly mirroring the
design of style
where there are directives that you can
specify and they can put in any order
directives are passed from left to right
and
if you specify something like white and
then red red winds because it's
spin the ground after okay white so can
you show us the documentation for web
horizontal layout or just and then yes
just one last thing that i wanted to
show you is that
just for the dominating we can start for
the rotation um
other than embedding youtube video
obviously we can do something
different here so you create an object
and then you write under code in here
um
and then basically you can specify the
size for example of the embedded object
that you want
okay so run that one
okay so
so just so i understand go ahead that's
here
yeah okay
so
and you can use the same template i was
doing before
um this is wonderful and this is action
yeah yeah this is now using the so run
[Music]
right now
probably it can be improved but this is
just a proof of concept i've been doing
today so
uh obviously it needs to be improved
what what what what's up so you said
this is using yarns and better
okay what what's not right about it what
what's happening here so like just to
prove that this is all real
the only thing is that
the loading is uh okay that loading is
wrong
yawn how does it get how should it be
cached
um
it depends a bit uh i mean you could
bake the cache into
the html that you produce but then it
will be
right in there of course has different
trade-offs
okay but but then it could refer to a
cache.html page
in addition
because is this in line
this is not a separate
yeah it's in line you can you could
implement show you what is up to import
the static html
and then
but the problem is it's no but then
you've burnt it in at the time you
create the web page that's the point
which you may or may not want to do but
but that's not an obviously stupid thing
to do to burn it in the time of web page
creation
okay just just to give me a sense of
this can you go back and redeploy that
thing with the embedded with the
embedded notebook piece and left
justified in the notebook
just show me how to do that
sorry so let's justify page you said
alignment change to alignment
no in in in the blog in the blog in the
blog
[Music]
so that's going into the web item okay
try to try that
but the the the problem here is that um
it's the
so here i specified that that this is
the cell itself has to be
do it on the right yes this is not
what's happening there i don't
understand this so the web item
it's in probably there are some box i'm
not sure about it but in theory these
should go on the right
but i don't understand that because
that's inside the web item the web item
is the iframe
the web item is the iframe that's being
told to be 420x420 oh
uh yes you're right
yes you're right i need another one
so
i need to do something like this i guess
did you have a concept of web items that
are just as large as they want to be or
as they need to be and then
adapting that to the embedded notebook
sorry again
no john is saying in his embedder you do
not have to pre-specify the size
of
um
uh the iframe it's just an embedding of
a thing at its natural size so to speak
yes i have been playing with this only
today so i need to to
take a look a little bit more to the
orientation and make it work with the
rest of the system okay but fine so then
that would probably be an automatic for
that second argument of web item that
would be an automatic
correct
um
yes so that basically
it will be the embedded that that yes it
will resize to whatever size it is
actually let's try that
the alignment should go here
the other important thing is the idea
that there are
uh css directives
sitting right in things like web item
right
yes it's very weird so we can
we can start to take a look at the
limitation yes um
okay so
as you can see like i've been trying to
mirror our style
so i'll put it here just
um you know so we can refer
the idea is that there are a lot of
directives so explicit option you can
specify a string there could be directly
a class thing
that is similar to to
basically saying something like style
expression title
uh the difference is that you can use
something like your class name in css
and then that it will be styled
accordingly to
whatever are the css rules that you're
planning
um then you can have a site's directive
and there is an explanation later on
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
that's some kind of weird css direct
thing so there's some set of options
from css that you can put directly into
web item is that correct
uh yes so yeah so this is this is part
of the design in meaning that anything
that is so there are options so symbols
that they have a meaningful work from
language that we are supporting but
every time you
write
a rule that is a string
that gets translated directly into css
which means that
as i'm showing here at some point
don't show us the most advanced case
okay okay
hold on hold on this is a mess okay this
is a mess okay hold on hold on you've
got like six different things going on
here okay that's a right hand side for
background it's being interpreted in css
right
no no no wait a minute background what
is quotes background
is that a css name
indeed
why is it
why is it got a capital b
gamut case
it's explaining it so basically you it
can be lowered case because css doesn't
matter so you could you could use
lowercase you could be
that's uppercase
wait a minute ricardo stop stop stop
okay i think if you read the text above
it's saying that basically it
automatically converts camera case
things to yeah i see that which is very
weird
i mean i think we should make a decision
either it's css based
and
or
it's
something where we have a curated list
of these things but having background in
quotes as well as background not in
quotes it's just like super confusing
am i making sense well background is a
special case though because it also has
a symbol for background i know the
border radius there isn't
yes i mean you can imagine background
should probably work on the camel case
yeah i mean i kind of think there's a
question of whether these options that
are the css options should be just you
know free range sitting in this
top-level function whether they should
be encapsulated in some kind of thing
that is called csx options arrow and
then some list or association i think
these should be encapsulated
i think it would be cleaner that way
it'd be cleaner but would you be able to
mix and match uh wolfram symbols with
css directors
well yes because in within one web item
you can have you know our top level
directives like background as a symbol
and then css options arrow
and then whatever css thing you want and
there will be some priority order i i i
think we just have to encapsulate the
name if we just wrap border radius in
like css
right because we can intermingle these
options in the order so the point is
that cody was saying that i see
i see i see
if you also there's an ordering problem
if you encapsulate them
in a css options because yeah okay we
get it we get it we get it it's not
going to work right so what you're
saying is what you're saying is a
proposal that there is a rapper
potentially or at least conceptually
there's a rapper we might as a courtesy
allow people to just give the strings
but there's conceptually a wrapper that
says web option
of quotes background does that make
sense
it does make sense but you need to
understand that when you are writing
something a little bit more
like this one like this big example that
idea okay let's see the example stop
jumping let's see the example
okay that's the danger of getting quite
verbose
if you've got twenty options you'd have
to keep saying well no i agree i agree i
agree i agree i agree so
stop jumping let's just stop for a
second so we can actually read it
okay all right
so
it's a web vertical layout web vertical
layout
okay so web item
is
is essentially an iframe is that correct
it's an embedded frame of some kind
of it's an iframe
but what is it
it's a box
okay
is it like a div
or it's just anything it could be
anything um from what i saw uh and
correct me if i'm wrong but from what i
saw it's a flexbox
so it's a div okay that uses a flexbox
yes
yes
okay all right so so
so let's see so that created
so
i could i have put a naked string there
in principle it would have just done
some default html if i'd done a naked
string without the web item there is
that correct ricardo
yes
yes it will work
okay if i show that would that have
worked or do i have to wrap it in the
web item
it would work
okay
but style presumably doesn't get an
aligner for it
um
well it means that it's a line on the
left
yeah
you see
what do you mean
hey oh
it's yeah sorry that's i needed to
update the load object
um
yeah the screenshot is right the the
link is not correct but it is the title
okay okay fine fine
okay
all right all right all right okay so if
if you were to deploy that again
okay all right so then then full comma
100
is the width
okay now what happens here
okay
okay terrific okay so let's just see
this hold on hold on hold on hold on
okay so the first thing is the totally
nft.com gray level one
black and white and things instead of
gray level zero on one um it might be
that i have copied this guy and
evaluated it you're right i will fix
this
okay
all right
okay so now web horizontal layout
what's next there
hyperlink then you will see wait
wait don't jump just hold on hold on
okay we're making a bunch of web items
in a table
which is
banana apple
those things right okay which i could
have just mapped if i wanted to okay so
then the hyperlink
is being built with url build
um
okay
and now those are just a horizontal
layout but where did the vertical bars
come from
uh which which one political bars
between banana and apple border right
okay fine so that's a css thing
i mean we could use um i i'm planning to
support frame
and so
uh i actually have examples already that
uh because
stop
today i started writing things for uh
for supporting frame
and frame directives uh but when i was
spreading this example this is just
using okay okay hold on hold on hold on
so
okay so just so i understand the flow of
our design right right now all these
things are pure
css
we may make our own version of these at
some point
that would become symbols
right
yes
so now that background why is that
background thing not our symbol
background no no not that one the one
above not that one not that one that one
there why is that one not our symbol
for background it could you could use
the same symbol
you could you could actually use yes
because background will translate
exactly to the css background okay so
fine but what about colors
so i mean
the thing is i i don't think like i
don't think there's ever going to be a
point where we have all of them because
they're like i don't know they're
probably thousands of css
yeah and there's probably a growing
number and somebody might have a special
version of css and who knows what
doesn't really matter
i'm just saying that we can there's
there's a border that might
progressively move as we support more
stuff natively because among other
things those things will be things that
we probably also support directly in
notebooks
like background is something we support
directly in notebooks
right yes now you will see something
that is kind of
um but there is no other way to do it at
least in my in my view
there is overloading this mouse over
directive
so as you can see here
when i'm already
ricardo you're jumping again okay
look
look okay no hacks
right
if this is something
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait look the point is
you're saying it's useful to have that
mouse over thing right
um
okay that is something that would also
be useful in notebooks
you can be ahead of notebooks here
implementing something like that but
let's not just sort of say oh it's often
a different world right if this is
something that's useful that's done with
our symbols not with some you know css
thing
then let's put it in the list to plan to
just do it
you see what i'm saying
yes i mean
that's not kind of spoiled
exactly this is not going to work i know
it would say background arrow that right
yes style doesn't
style
like
in style you often don't have to put the
like actual option name you just throw
directives in
indeed
but this is
yeah you can use it for is pointing out
on a livestream that notebooks predate
css that is in indeed completely the
case
long predate css
anyway go go ahead
no well what you can do is obviously to
use mouse over and and specify a
complete web by the mirror complete with
item here there are examples in the
regulation that works
okay fine what i'm saying is
when you have a nice syntax like that
then it goes into the queue to be
something that we potentially implement
for notebooks rather than it's just a
random hack
you see what i'm saying no sure
doesn't mean that we can't use it in web
item before we have it implemented in
notebooks
but it should be oh it's just a random
hack that you have to remember works in
web item and it will never work anywhere
else
so one thing i'm pondering which i can't
think of a counter example but i'm
worrying about is
the idea that the um option name is a
string means css seems like that's
pretty safe but having the if you look
at the one pixel solid hashtd
the argument that the value of the
option there is a string is being
interpreted as css but we do have values
of the strings within
that have orphan language
interpretations for some options
and is there ever going to be an
ambiguity about whether this is a
wolfram style name or a css class or you
know or something has been
like that which could have been symbolic
in the wolf language
i called that example but well i'm sure
there are one out there i mean there are
potentially examples
i can i can think about what i never
encountered well i can tell you one
there are appearance options which are
strings
right where the right hand side is a
string do we have anybody from the front
end team here
connor
no no
they're like a for button isn't there
like appearance inactivated and stuff
like that if you want an example yes
i i did want to ask i mean what
what is the precise relationship between
sort of the meaning of a web vertical
layout and a column
um
because obviously you know we're
assuming that there is something
inherently web-ish about what we're
representing here
and obviously you know css specific css
styles are an example of that
um
but i i feel like i we need a better
understanding of why do we need a
special symbol yeah i can give a little
bit of background
of historically how we ended up at that
point which was that one of the original
motivators was that layout's all done by
grid column at the moment
but they have um you know their design
premises to try and accommodate the
things you put in them rather than to um
allocate space to things so they're
working for the inside outwards more
than the outside inwards
so the layouts um things we're supposed
to think about it from the outside
inwards you are going to have one third
of the space available for this and
whatever goes in it has to fit
whereas grid says this is a big thing
i'm going to make the column bigger it's
kind of default design
now i think in an earlier design review
it was thought that the front end
is not in a position to look at this
stuff
you know for a couple of years
in the same
level of detail and so i think it was
stephen and suggested well maybe we
should just have a web vertical layout
and a web horizontal layout to make it
clear that it's a web world and i was
going to bring that up as a question is
that even if something can't catch up
for a while is actually a good decision
or should these yes just be a good
decision
because i think what we should be doing
here this is a pure wrapper for you know
this is just symbolic assistance for
creating web pages
if you really have no idea you know
simple web pages you'll probably be able
to create this way but if you don't know
some webby stuff you're not going to be
able to do fancy stuff here
and i think it's the right thing to do
this and even in the front end i had a
project recently that it is actually
quite difficult to say i want a 3x3 grid
where i want the
things to take up one third of the space
no doubt no doubt but that's not
something that's going to be solved
immediately but it's already solved in
web technology and we should just be
using that
right
so
there's one design question we had
i wanted to bring up we
what about web row and web column
instead of web vertical layout and web
horizontal layout i'd be fine with that
if we think that's sensible
maybe it sounds too much like row or
column you know
if they're not no i'm not worried about
it but um
well is it compatible with row and
column or not well row raps and i think
these things if you say you've got uh
horizontal layers of three things you
expect them to be three things
unless you've got a interface switched
maybe we should have an mp collection if
you shrink it by default it should stay
for now this is going to start as an
experimental function we can do it
that's not exactly true are we talking
about okay just specifically layout or
are we saying like because you i could
see lists long lists that will wrap
during
responsiveness right so are we supposed
to be using
horizontal layout in those situations
are we not supposed to
i can see that you know laying out eight
items that will wrap nicely as you
shrink the page down yes so wait a
second web horizontal layout what does
it do
in the case where you're showing there
on the screen on the right before
ricardo jumps again
the what what are you showing okay so
that particular case is a wrapping row
is that correct
yes
so so so show us that go go to that url
go to that url uh also also this is what
could you specified as
sure
okay now
so how would i specify if i wanted that
not to wrap but i want some things to
grow and shrink
you can
stall
you're going to bars but i mean this is
at least what i have been doing so there
are scroll bars at some point here
and um
and so you have a web horizontally auto
and when you see true it doesn't drop
anymore now i'm
not sure if
if
but what if i don't want scotland i just
want to have three pictures to be side
by side i want them to get smaller when
you
when you resize in that case right now
in the in the in the in the actual
design you will need to use our css
directly that says do not block
okay so how would i type that in
hold on hold on i've got web horizontal
layout and then i want that css
directive there so i just put it as a
string right there is that correct
indeed i don't remember specifically
right on top of my head what is the
exact
rule that you need to
specify um probably flex without
and should be something like
i guess uh it's a white space no wrap
something like this okay no rap but now
it's shrinking
cody just told you what it should be
white space no rap
uh actually flextrap would probably
that's that's probably right yeah
yeah
so so is there some fundamental
difference in the philosophies between
the horizontal and the vertical layout
in this regard
um
no not really other than one is a flex
column and the other one is uh is a flex
he's a
uh the the thing is
what what we are doing with with with
all those options when you are
specifying the size specification and
everything
uh
flex is is vector based meaning that you
always think internal vector and then
you just relate it
and and the way you apply like the fact
that that that you are uh specifying
that items should be
uh
you know feed the whole
viewer of the previous element is still
vector based and so you need to to use
flex grow
in in one case if you want to to
to shrink it horizontally and another
property if you want to do it vertically
depending if you are not okay this is
way too much detail that's way too much
detail we've got other things to look at
so let's go ahead one of the motivation
things originally that i set out to
answer the question obviously if i
wanted to build an id like interface or
even for example when you've got there
on screen
in notebooks what were the missing
primitives and in that case you know in
that inspector you've got open if you
resize that you kind of don't want the
thing just immediately say oh i'm just
going to put these vertically because
they fit better you want that to
you know to try and hold its layout and
decide i want the space the frame of the
left to be the one to give up show
interface switch please you had some
examples of um i i think that in any
case you can do like an item that is an
absolute size of 4000 pixels for example
and that will
will go off of the screen so that won't
drop so if you if you manually look like
an outside wrapper that is going off the
screen
in that case it will it will go up
ricardo we have a limited amount of time
to review this could you could you
please show interface switched
indeed
show an example of excuse me show an
example of its use you had one you had
you had an example oh okay you can do it
there if you want to i was saying okay
so
so this is very simple example here and
and yeah what you do is you just resize
and it changes
so
this is a top level interface switch
meaning that you switch the whole thing
so just like mouse over it's like when
you when you move the screen from here
to here you see the content here is also
changing but if canvas we use to switch
single properties so in this example i'm
switching instead of on the device size
on the fact that if you print it
something else up here so please
remember to resign with this data stuff
like that so you can talk hold on you're
jumping again
scroll back up let's go back up let's go
back up okay so we've got interface
switched what it the first argument is
which i remember this design from like
two years ago whenever is what it is
switching on
so it can switch on device type or it
can switch on what was the other thing
you had down there
uh well there are several things here so
the orientation whatever is portrait or
vertical
um
the
yeah
let's see here for example print screen
and speech which is what i was showing
here
um okay this is fairly nice
if we want this to also to be not just a
web thing then you would want it
interface switch to also be am i in the
wolfen cloud or am i on a business it's
not
this is a web thing for now we're going
to prototype this whole functionality in
the web just for the web
common use case though because because
we don't have 100 support and a front
end in the cloud you want sometimes okay
if we're down that's it this is a
different thing we might use the
interface switched function for other
things but for right now it's just for
the work well it leads to my second
observation which is what happens if i
want to switch in a combination that i
want it's this is what happens if it's
in a vertical layout and it's smaller it
can be confused i don't have examples
here but it can become consuming
oh you nest them okay and
yes
and does it make any difference if i
nest the um the vertical inside the
the small or the small inside vertical
i guess it could make a difference but
that's something to think about
i guess it could make a difference but
in theory it works obviously like it's
like
exactly
it's actually using logical composition
of
all those all those things and so it
basically compares to a single directive
that
down the tree it
it it incorporates all the all the
switches you have done until that point
could you scroll up again please scroll
up again please
so so those things at the top
are
the settings
right we discussed this i mean it's been
years but we discussed this
all right
i i i can say i can say that basically
this design can be used in the front
that we are
like everything else that i have been
showing is web specific but this design
could be
in theory
uh you know use inside the front end
because
there is no
when we were doing it we were actually
making sure also which on foods and
other people from the front and team
that these which for who for some reason
were not invited to this meeting but you
know
sorry it's wearable here a synonym of
tiny is that what that means the way
it's documented
there isn't some property that the
browser knows about what it's running on
it's it's just looking normal
this is no no this is this actually
applies to 320 pixels which is why it's
not right here
sorry so
in all of my 16 attendees which one did
i miss
people from the front end team okay john
thought to somebody else we will get
someone next time okay
um okay this is very nice ricardo okay
so hold on let's um
this is really nice okay can we see the
documentation for the other things now
web
um
okay so whereby okay you want to show
web item next okay scroll to the top
let's see this where by the most was the
depending on what you want to cover so
how much
is there a guide page okay there are
four like four functions here right
there's interface switch web item
horizontal layout vertical layout is
that correct
yes i haven't done a guide
just those four items
okay so
okay if my expression is raw html and i
obviously i can code that up as xml
elements but if i actually have a string
that is some more html uh what do i do
verbatim or
so
in this case so the the the
there is like this
um
you can put it very very minute and it
will be basically uh yes
incorporated inside the page the right
thing to do will be to drop it inside
embed the html which is a wrapper that
we have in the system that works too
that and so basically
what we should do is that you mark a
certain string to be basically html
because
in theory a lot of framework are not
allowing the user to just take a string
and inject it directly because but if i
put a string that was for example less
than b greater than i should see that on
the page i should see the the less than
greater than signs it shouldn't say i'm
a b tag
unless i write and that's the better
html problem yes this is what i'm saying
unless you guys so do we escape the
strings or not when if i put a string in
there
exactly
and but right now this is not happening
right now a string will be injected
directly and it will be transformed
inside this okay so hold on inside a web
item what experts can there be you're
not documenting that here
we are not downloading that yet no and
you need to don't you should have a list
yeah you need to document it so what is
that list so if i put an image there
presumably that will work correct image
graphics bunch of stuff from working yes
okay so fine there's got to be a list
right and and one of those things could
be either in the web item or elsewhere
embedded html is that correct
yes an embedded service should also work
which is like a youtube video or
something right embedded service which
is supported in the cloud should also
work here
correct so my i think my vote here would
be that if the expert is divorced ring
it should be escaped and so effectively
protects you against xss attacks if
you're
not aware of them and you should make
the effort to say treat this literally
by wrapping it in an embedded html i
agree
this is something that we should do at
some point the problem is um
we need to make sure that it propagates
well
against the system
we shouldn't have web item of a string
work
okay it should just not work
right that feels like the kind of thing
you really want to be able to do map web
item down a list of things you just pull
out of a database and not have to
do some kind of export string on each of
them to too
obviously it needs to work right i mean
how do you write something like hello
earth
okay fair enough fair enough okay fair
enough fine
okay
okay
so
okay let's look at web horizontal layout
web vertical layout
and then then please we do need to
introduce this web page function right
web page wrapper
and and obviously that will have it's
the obvious
pieces of
i don't even know what those are the
things that give the title and so on
what is that going to be an association
what are those there shouldn't be loose
random string options that should be an
association of metadata shouldn't it
in the web page wrapper
it could probably be the second argument
and yes it could be an association
probably
i used to have something here
so
well that's nice that looks pretty good
yeah
we should just implement that
any reason not to i would spell out
javascript probably better javascript um
i am i'm not so sure about this design
so for
for this design review i've implemented
only those things so that we can because
i know that for example uh the the
metadata problem has been solved things
for the cloud right here and i i think
there is a way to specify metadata for
notebooks for example and so john could
you just say the answer to that please
in cloud deploy this way of specifying
metadata
is that correct uh
no not yet but we thought about a
separate option for that um what was it
uh information or something
a metro information for cloud deploy
information does have a
have a special meaning array that's
that's general cloud objects
meta information matter information that
is so the main point here is to merge
the concepts for web page
i mean maybe we should just use the web
page wrapper
if you say exposure options was an idea
at some point
okay
okay so you you yarn and ricardo need to
talk about this and try and figure this
out and possibly the right answer here
john would be to wrap
webpage around the cloud deploying hell
that maybe it's a stupid idea i was
thinking you know
oh it's a stupid idea is it a stupid
idea i don't know you tell me if if if
we want to put metadata on a web page of
a thing that is being deployed like just
a random manipulator or something what
about saying cloud deploy of web page of
manipulate comma and then the options to
the web page
comments
yarn ricotta i think that would that
would do something but it would not
necessarily produce the same thing as
deploying the manitou itself but that
would go through ricardo's framework to
construct a web page i know that but i
mean what is the difference in the end
what is the difference between those two
things
so if you cloud deploy and manipulate it
will be just a notebook as far as the
you know cloud file system is concerned
it's it's a notebook
but when it goes through a recorder
system it produces an html
page that includes the notebook or
okay
we
we could uh
we we could use the same system that
we're using now right right now we're
doing a switch over the first argument
of cloud deploy roughly right so
we could switch
again if you find web pages which again
on the first start connected web page
uh but we suggest still use the same
part but but then we need to have some
common way of passing those options so
that they work on what system
no no no
we're getting confused here look look
what what yarn is saying is there are
things like
title of page right
which can be done
for the deployed notebook in yarn system
without any additional html wrapping
by title of page you mean the title like
this title the title of the top right
yes that's what i mean yes
right and so most likely what we want is
an option that can be given both to
cloud deploy and to web page
to specify those
that those what yarn was describing as
web exposure options
exactly and if we do that probably this
option could be embedded directly and
say well by then meaning that webpage is
not necessary no
no
no
no
no
well we need web page so that what you
do is you say cloud publish of web page
not cloud publisher web item cloud
publisher web page we're going to need
additional metadata for web page i
absolutely guarantee that will be whole
page information about you know
whatever it is about css imports about
other random stuff no we need to see
that wrapper
seo tags
yes among among many others
but wouldn't this option be what i was
saying web page meta information which
you'd already started designing for
cloud as an option to cloud object and
cloud that makes perfect sense yes yeah
right that makes perfect sense
and it should be in both things and
there should be a web page wrapper even
if all it does right now is pretty much
what the same as web item does but we
will need more stuff there
plus the semantics okay so again let's
look at web vertical layout for a second
please
oh we do not have documentation there so
is web horizontally uh more documented
yes so basically
just show us web horizontal layout then
if if that's the one that's documented
just show us that
well hello okay so that's it's not
different
i know it's not different so ddd
uh
what i've done is to basically this part
is common so
i would rather yeah
here the usage line is a bit different
not that much
what changes is that the x prior if you
put the list in web item is going to be
verbatim list so it will actually show a
list inside it
if you put a list near it will create
and why is it
that that isn't just web item of row and
column
why by the way i call them
because they do not accept all this
stuff
that we do except like
css specification and everything
okay
but what's the difference between web
item
other than what's the difference between
web item which accepts those options
and
web vertical layout what web item with
one
only one item not not much no
is similar to web vertical horizontal
layout is that correct or web vertical
layout yes
yes it is similar if you if you don't
specify any option yes
okay so maybe we should be calling these
web column webrow
is there any reason we shouldn't do that
i'm sorry
sorry i was going to ask earlier but
then we moved on i mean is the
difference between
a web say web vertical layout and a
column
the webbiness of it or the fact that the
layout you know uh behavior is different
i think it's so it's webby layout we
don't know
by the way recall i just want to comment
you cannot use you cannot use ordering
as an option
over on the right hand screen just
remove it
you cannot use that
it is stanton
yeah right you cannot use that
that's a function that does something
completely different
i know i know yes i will remove it i
will actually know it it's just a
temporary fact
okay okay so back to connor's question
i mean uh and the point i was thinking
there are obviously things like embedded
css styling directives which are very
web specific but the you know the
broader design here is a thing which
represents a vertical column of stuff
which
lays out following kind of flexbox style
layout behavior um and that's not
necessarily web specific and even the
thing you mentioned is that this design
or maybe it was john sorry who mentioned
earlier this design came was kind of
was envisioned as a simplified way to
get something working for web pretty
quickly you know without having to touch
the
questions of how would the front end
implement behavior like this
but i still wonder if
if the design we want isn't something
closer to a more general
this is a flex column kind of thing and
whether that's you know maybe we only
let you deploy that to the web for now
but
you know that that would be the symbol
we would have and it would be behavior
you're getting is that this is a flex
column that lays out what is it what's
the what is the definition of a flex
column
well i think it would be i mean it's the
difference and this is where cody or
people who know more about web stuff
than i do could step in but
the layout that we have
uh
versus it's it's kind of
um how do i describe this like can
somebody who knows just jump in yeah
cause somebody just
how it fills the the row like if you
have a flex row right it
it has predefined ways of how it
populates how it fills up the space
vertically or horizontally
yeah
with xbox it kind of fills up the space
um whereas with
a row it doesn't fill up the space
but but also critically as as ricardo is
showing on the screen there are like you
know a hundred options for all these
things
yeah it's a really flexible system um
but for the simple things which is just
let's bang out a layout
all you really need is flex row and flex
column with some with some widths right
so the general point is it's it's for
responsiveness right so you can you know
as you resize stuff everything stretches
correctly that kind of
mean yeah
yeah with with which is which is why um
i like
which is why i like differentiating it
between row and flex row like they are
conceptually two different ways of
laying things out
look i think what we should do
the goal here is to have experimental
functionality in 13 that lets you build
web pages easily i don't think we will
not get the design right
for you know something which is going to
be more general than just essentially a
wrapper for css and so on so the
question here the only question here is
whether i would think that this flex
column flex row thing will ultimately be
options to column and row
is that obviously wrong or not
and there might be some other thing
called flex column which is a version of
column that has certain options preset
is that obviously wrong anybody column
and row kind of to me
refers more to like tables
and with the kind of the flexible
designs and responsiveness
we you know they moved away from table
designs
so i don't know if if that really
works
without however i wouldn't
certainly isn't like tables rose is
kind of
it's like a box version of text wrapping
which i guess is like a flex row but
with very specific set of
defaults well
is uh yeah it's it's more like text
wrapping for
objects
okay listen it sort of fills up for
right
okay we have one decision to make are we
calling them web column and webrow are
we calling them web horizontal web
vertical for example
if again like i i think they can be
called column narrow because if you if
you just do web column and web road they
look like column level
meaning that
they will
like web horizontal layout with one two
three inside will just look like row one
two three they will be
addition to each other
and and that's the same for web vertical
layout now obviously the moment you
start adding options they will start
looking and behave differently but
that's why they're called web complement
as opposed to
right
yeah
yeah okay who disagrees with the idea
hold on does anybody disagree with the
idea of calling this webron web column
well i still have a concern that one day
the front end catches up and we have to
rename them
yes yes one day webrow and web column
it's a complicated thing because the web
might have advanced you know the
augmented reality web might have all
kinds of wacky things that we don't have
in the front end because we don't care
um and the front end may advance in its
own way and eventually it may be the
case that you can put into a web page
outer wrapper front end primitives
that do the equivalent of a flex column
and i don't see any problem with that
this is the raw
web thing that's going to be full of css
still mulling over the idea that these
are just row and column and we're just
adding options that only support it in
the world no no no absolutely not would
be a big mistake
if if i can jump in here real quick like
the the thing is also this is we have
considered this to be lower level like
you know the front-end mile at some
point compile raw or other stuff to this
guy so that it works for uh for the web
and then we can have other tasks after
work you know targeting android or ios
or switched ui or whatever it is but in
the end you're always going to need like
specific tools that are going to map
more closely to what to how you know the
the system you're targeting
uh is working right okay so listen
listen okay so let's change these names
to webron web column
i have one very trivial point
web page is it a capital p or not
yes
anybody got an opinion about that
capital p what do
no
not necessary
because we're going to end up with
having flex capabilities for our row and
column
this is this is it's not i mean unless
you have an objection because of
something about web
web programming that makes you think
column is something different is that
your objection cody no uh no it's it's
it's more
naming it explicitly what it what it
will be will be a little bit easier to
make that mental bridge between
but it's totally fine
so let's web row web column web page
with a capital p
okay
wouldn't
if it were two words and already people
sometimes write it as one word i know
that i know that it's a smooshing word
the problem is that all these other
things are web x and people are going to
get wrong all the time
i mean this is why we went to well but
is it a web page or is it a is it a page
within is is it called page within the
web framework or is it is it called web
page
it's called a page you are making a page
within the web framework therefore it is
a web page with a capital p
that's my coincidence that it sounds
like uh the word web page exactly it's
the same thing that happened with geo
position we had all this trouble with
geo position we eventually decided to
just make a pseudo word geo
so that we didn't end up with some
things having geo lower case whatever
and some things you know geo coordinates
with the lowercase g position with a
capital and so on we just made a pseudo
word so i think that's what we should do
here
um
last alternative even to make it like
you know even lower level would be to
call them html item html
no
no
i don't think so
we don't need that i don't think we
should do that oh also it might make it
sound i mean
i i don't really know enough about html
but if there's something called a row or
column in html that isn't a flexbox it
might also mislead people to thinking oh
this is a a row which is the
old-fashioned thing that i don't want
there isn't uh the old school thing are
tables that nobody uses the new school
thing is flexbox which we are currently
using in this in this thing
okay okay now um
okay somebody needs to work with ricardo
and some details of this documentation
because it isn't quite right
like that size directive thing shouldn't
be pointed that way todd you could
probably help with that yeah yeah yeah
we have not gone through the document
review level
in terms of formatting and i think this
is a very excellent thing and it's going
to be super useful
okay
we got a few other questions on
yes can i just jump in with one question
to make sure we got resolved
the issue about you know free range css
as options
did we
i i don't like that automatic d camel
casing
no that's crazy
bonkers
just
free range no decambling
and no wrapper like
css open bracket correct
correctly it's a free range but it is
css strings and that's why it has a web
prefix for the name of the function
okay
so if you just find like background and
then you have css background is it just
the order
of how it's just that's the second one
is takes
left to right yes
okay we have some questions on live
stream which are interesting one is
should there be a theme option how do we
deal with themes
how do we deal with html themes
isn't that just like saying i want to
import a style sheet if we had themes as
css you would just
yes i guess so there's also a question
here what happened to css importing
that isn't isn't it the case in this
model that you simply say
you know import a css file you can you
can give that as a an option to web page
saying
use this css
you know import the css which means you
can use css definitions from there isn't
that correct
oh yeah yes in the webpage that i was
showing before like if i can find it
yeah here
is confusing right i mean you're like
linking to some to some style sheet but
the point is is that i don't think we
have a way of representing i mean maybe
as json or something like uh most stuff
that's interesting
yeah i mean we could represent it as
like a big association thing well okay
but notice that we could a
representative association which
probably would be useful but notice also
that in our new web item we can import
no actually we can't we can't import the
definitions
i don't know
i mean that might be one thing worth
thinking about though is if if we did
want to support import for like dot css
files whatever representation it has it
might be nice if you could put it into
web item
yes that is right
that's right there is a tentative
representation of style sheet that i was
doing here and basically yes you use an
association with the
advantage in our interface which we also
represent media query and then
everything else is just something like
this i mean the whole
thing selector is going on the left hand
side and then on the right hand side you
have an association and the left hand
side is the prop
and yeah it's just a value should
actually technically be a shouldn't it
be a list of rules and not an
association because you could have
repeats
no because repeats they do
um like if you repeat something it gets
deleted in any case
cascading i mean if you define you know
p and then you give some styles and
lower down you say key and you give some
other styles that don't maybe that don't
overlap and i think both of those apply
don't they
uh
but the way you define level you're
right
yes
is pointing out that
kevin daly did a talk about converting
css to
wolfram language style sheets two years
ago apparently
somebody should find out about that we
can ask kevin
okay can somebody do that please
no brady can you get that to happen
please
yeah we'll we'll talk to him okay
okay
um
okay
uh
let's see there's another question here
um about
math
formatting math
um
what are we doing with that
what happens if you have a piece of math
that is with our boxes how is that
formatted here
um
well everything that is at some point
like
a lot of things just be rasterized and
the and in the html exporter there are
options and you can choose you know what
what's no no no i want a practical
answer here somebody has
a you know a piece of math the result of
some integral okay what's going to
happen to it when you
no no no no really practical question
okay i'm i'm typing it right now i'm
saying cloud publish web item
integrate blah blah blah i get the
result of the integral okay or
traditional form of that
it's going to make some reasonable web
page right now or that's for the future
or what's the story
um
just try it just try it just try it
right now
just do it do it do it why why do you
have to say well whatever okay integrate
one over x to the fourth minus one
whatever you want
oh this is svg
that's right it's an sdg or is it like a
jpeg
by default we are right now before what
is it what is it ricardo just answer the
png
okay so it got it got bitmaps
okay it can't be but it can be
parameterizing in the html
export option meaning that you can
decide to use svg like that
in the last two three years
maybe even more like psvg exported that
we have got much much better
okay and we just gotta make a practical
decision all that matters is what the
default is
okay so we have to decide what is the
default for this
and and what about using i mean
yarn what are you doing now in the cloud
for this
uh well it's html uh you know but that's
the whole magic of our javascript based
notebook renderer
which is not available in these
standalone web pages
right
okay all right so we know how much
choice here right
if if you could turn them into boxes
then there would be a way to render a
notebook on the fly or you know render
boxes on the fly but i think that's
overkill
here it's not necessary for right now
it's a future enhancement
okay last question and then we gotta
wrap this um
there's a comment here about generating
react
i think that's a that's a
separate issue that's the next project
of being able to produce
right that we're just producing here raw
html plus css right there's nothing
fancier than that is that correct
ricardo
correct we don't have a way to yeah to
use dynamic module or things like that
right so that's for the future it's it's
a very it's a way to make very basic
layouts very quickly
which seems super useful to me
and okay question for our web actual
deployment people who are here
i mean
is is this completely usable by us
or is it something where we have to have
all kinds of corporate templating and
all kinds of other stuff to make this
actually useful
but let's say we want to deploy i don't
know we're doing some webinar or
something and we want to deploy pages
for it will this well what's presented
here allow us to deploy a page or not
i think so i mean from from we're just
creating a one-off web page that's no
problem um i think right but
don't we have corporate headers and
things like that would they be
includable here or is that no because
most of that is
using um the server side includes to
pull in all of those of course we can
create a version of it that we can pull
in but that's just another
another version that we have to keep um
hold on hold on hold on let me explain
let me understand that you're saying
that
let's say a standard page that supports
who knows what you know
headers at the top live chatting on the
side footers at the bottom all this kind
of stuff right a bunch of corporate
stuff
that is done with the server side
include in modern in the modern world is
that true right because
yeah we have hundreds of of pages that
need to look the same so we have one
file that gets pulled in okay so now my
question is could this pull that file in
as well could this framework of
ricardo's pull that file in also
uh in theory yes yeah but it would be on
deploy time right so
uh well i guess there's different
different ways to do it so if you're
publishing a page you would have to pull
it in at the time of publish or you have
to
use a kernel to import it in real time
the cloud does support uh server side
includes uh though they don't like that
they support server siding
right that is purely by accident yeah we
i think it would be nice to have an
official way to support that and
officially document that but
at this point i don't consider that an
official feature
so could you expect this could be a
motivation to do that you know we could
have
a way to
expose that through web item or web page
and then make that
produce html that is officially working
in the cloud
wait a second just just can somebody
just explain this to me in a simple way
that okay so we have a framework for
server side includes which are being
used
by our web
i see we're being used by our web server
that is our web server our corporate web
server has server side includes which
are splattered onto every page at the
time when the page is served is that
correct that is correct it's the it's
the headers and footers on most of the
most wolfram pages
right okay fine so
okay so but that's a feature of our web
server and the point is if you're giving
this to somebody else
their web server might have a server
side include possibility as well but the
plumbing of how you connect to their
server side includes is not obvious
you would just put the code in and you
just need to know where the file is so
it would work if their server is enabled
with with server side to include
so ricardo can you copy the thing
i put in chat i think this is roughly
what it would look like
it would just be replaced like a simple
text for the virtual include
um directive
okay fine i see so that would just be a
pure embedded html that has that include
there yep and if it references a place
that is on the server and it's enabled
then it can pull it okay fine and so
then the only other comment that was
being made was in our cloud
right if you were to put that
server-side include thing in our cloud
the web server in question is our cloud
web server which doesn't have a clue how
to find some random include from so the
one question is can it find our
corporate includes and then could it
find somebody else's random include we
would have to include it specifically on
the cloud it wouldn't be able to
discover what's on wolfram.com no i
understand that i understand it would
need it would need to be on the file
system
right so that doesn't seem undoable
right i mean to have a a
for us at least
to have that includable there
uh that's what we that's what we do
currently for the resource system and
functional repository it's another place
that they have to maintain it but yeah
big deal so that's why we have all kinds
of automation for release engineering
hopefully
um all right this is great
boy we are we are i'm sorry this this
lasted longer than we expected and it's
causing some timing problems here but um
that's okay we're this is very good
anybody want to make any final comments
here this is great ricardo well done
very nice it's really good thank you
um
that's going to be super useful for many
people
um okay so todd you're gonna you're in
charge of like making you know
documentation cleaning and and so on
right
yep i'm taking notes about the decisions
we've made
okay
and i suspect there will need to be one
more round
which i would suggest doesn't
necessarily have to involve me
at least one more round looking at a few
details about weird things in
interactions with the web and so on um
and uh
um
then let's try building some web pages
with us and i mean uh you know the
default responsiveness that you have
ricardo
it's it's based on modern web frameworks
and it's reasonable is that the idea
yeah it is based on standard technology
like media release
right
the default thing if i just put a list
out there the thing you showed with a
row where i just put a list it'll just
it'll wrap in a decent way
yes
and it will be responsive
yes i mean yeah because it will drop
with the with the width size but then if
you want to have more complex behavior
you need to specify to yourself for
example as you see here there are three
items and they've dropped down to two
and this is specified here in the
example using interface boost
by basically moving from size that is
one third it's actually pretty simple to
one half
but
you need to find this kind of logic
depending on your content that's fine
that's what one expects
okay terrific so one one last comment um
for the virtual includes
it's hard to test it locally on your
machine because your computer usually
doesn't have any of that stuff so
what we did with the physics projects we
you know we implemented a local one
where if you deployed locally to look at
the page you can see it but we had to
you know extract the header and footer
and put it on
how we generate the pages but then when
we deployed to the server then we
included the virtual include stuff so
that the server can just pull it in so
there's a
slight you know development while you're
developing you might have to do
something well so maybe there's a way
that we can parametrize that so that so
that you can have so the virtual include
thing becomes its own symbolic wrapper
so that we can do a better job of that
in other words basically what you're
saying
john was saying
interface switched he would like a case
where it does one thing if you're in the
cloud and one thing if you're on the
desktop you see what i'm saying so what
you're effectively saying is that that
include that virtual include
should know oh i'm running on my
somebody's personal computer so don't
try and do the virtual include from this
file do it from that file instead it's
the same type of argument that i'm not
sure well that would have to be done on
deploy time right i guess i'm not sure
how how it would affect the page because
a plain
page is not going to know if you're if
you're viewing from the cloud versus
viewing from your local machine it's
it's all on on i know but it's it's got
to be deployed you don't get to see it
anyway it's got to be deployed somehow
okay so then the deployment
the code would be smart enough to know
if you're yeah right the virtual include
knows it's like an interface switch
mechanism for the virtual include that
knows
when it is i admit that that's deploy
time thing rather than a rather than a a
viewing time thing
okay anyway so i mean the system
everything is compiled
and um and basically
yes but this is a compile time question
it's not something when you're testing
you are running it on your local web
server as opposed to on the on the big
fancy corporate web server
right when you are when you're testing
it you are compiling for your local
server as opposed to compiling for the
global one
makes sense
okay
um
see
ethan is asking for
um
uh making sure that our gallery view
works in the setting which it should
right ricardo
um probably gallery view can be
rewritten with this framework but yes
that's that's that's right we should
give a note of this
um
also comment another comment from ethan
about drop down menus and things like
that what are what what of those are you
supporting here
um
not we we don't have a primitive for
drop down do we in the front end
yes we do so unfortunately all the
controls
yeah
we have tons of them
we have stopped up many right but that
is that is another thing and i'm not
aware of
drop down
i mean you well fine
yeah you can you can embed uh
standard regular html on this so you
could do the select element that's a
good point if you want to do drop-downs
yes it's it's for now it's still like do
it yourself solution we don't have an
eye level right so okay that's the thing
to look at with respect to the you know
seeing what front-end capabilities we
have seen what can be put into this web
framework etc yeah right
the things the things that you would
want to put in are like form page or a
gallery view we would want to make sure
that those
will integrate nicely
i agree
can you comment on that the
form are already working i don't have
examples here but like you can put a
form object here it would work the
problem is that is the action that you
need to define and so for that it's like
what happens when you click submit and
where it's pointing to this is
completely static for now it can be
included instead of delayed but like
the way they interact with each other is
okay let me let me translate
right because there's an issue that we
had that john looked at several years
ago right if you have an embedded form
on that page right
then right now what you're saying is the
submit button will go to a new page it
will just blow away everything that the
page you had it will not be able to
submit in page and have that why can't
you have it inside a web item why can't
you have the submit inside a web item
that acts like an iframe
do you understand what i'm saying
because it's already
kind of working i mean i mean i don't
know like i haven't tested it in full
generality and it's not augmented right
now so like i i i still need to work on
this but wait wait theory like
you can put a form okay so type
something into that form type something
in
but this is a file
or it's like the the server doesn't know
how to respond to that call
and and so you you will need to add like
something that says okay i want this
form to be submitted to this cloud
object or in general to this url no but
i'm saying that if you put a form
function in there another form object a
form function
that does something right
put a form form function in theory this
okay so this
this
is something
make it do something just put the inter
put a number there and let's say hash
second squared or something right yeah i
mean by default just do it just put it
in there
whatever
okay whatever amazon whatever yes okay
now try it
try typing something in there
there is no submit there is no logic in
here it's it it won't work
but
what i'm saying is that i mean obviously
we we can
we can try to think what this should do
yes
when we do cloud deploy of this maybe
yes it will replace
the
the whole thing with the function
content uh
maybe
right now you can iframe in a form page
and it'll work that's what we do for a
lot of contact pages is we iframe in a
form page
all right so you should be able to do
that too here
but then at compile at compile time you
will need to collect this guy
and deploy it
separately that's right which is not
something that we are doing right now
okay fine but
the interim what can be done is what
kodi is already doing which is to deploy
the form page separately then i frame it
into the symbolic page
right
does that make sense one way to do it
there is that is one way to do it okay
so that additional automation would
allow
you know this is this gets into the
category of creating bundles of pages i
suspect
bundles of objects
right to be able to do that
objects and assets
yeah
all right anyway this is great stuff
thank you very much
and um
uh
let's see
i we are going to another live stream
for people who are following that it is
about
pde modeling oh boy we've got multiple
ones coming up